more than 300 people have been killed
across turkey and Syria after a
magnitude 7.8 earthquake struck the
southeastern region of pizzazz but
trimmers were felt in several provinces
around there as well as Syria and
Lebanon in Syria alone the death toll
already stands at 230. the Tremor lasted
a minute causing hundreds of buildings
to collapse
turkey is reporting upwards of 70 deaths
and as day breaks Rescuers are
frantically searching for survivors
we ask our citizens outside the affected
region to reduce their mobile phone
activities especially I would like to
warn everyone about this information
sharing any misleading information
through social media now would be the
biggest reason to this country
or for more on this I am now joined by
Sanam kosiolu who's monitoring
developments for us from Istanbul and
Cinema obviously a huge earthquake like
this requires a huge emergency response
what's the government been doing so far
well Tom this is one of the biggest
earthquakes that turkey has experienced
within the last couple of decades
following Istanbul earthquake back in
1999. currently I'm seeing that Turkish
foreign minister vice president and the
Parliamentary spokesperson are speaking
on a live describing the details of the
situation and the measures the
government has been taken has been taken
since early morning today we first heard
in Turkish interior Minister who is in
charge of the disaster management agency
talk about the issues and he said that
rescue workers have been dispatched to
the area and many Governors are I'm
sorry many Governors were also deployed
to the area by the order of the Turkish
president and he said that he made a
call that in order not to interrupt any
rescue works or any health facilities
ambulances reaching to the area and
citizens shouldn't be taking to the
roads with their cars but the situation
is there of course as you can imagine
because the earthquake was a
7.4 magnitudes according to turkey's
disaster management agency but to some
other outlets it was 7.4 one of the
biggest of its kind and it affected 10
cities in Eastern Turkey it was even
felt in Black Sea city of trap zone
is met Cyprus Lebanon Syria damaging in
many buildings and so far according to
the official figures seven to six people
have been have been have died under
under the leveled buildings and many
buildings have leveled in the area in
some of the Cities including the
epicenter Karma Maharaj pazard district
and malathia
and other places and this is a very
difficult time for the Turkish
government who has increased its alarm
level to level four which also requires
International assistance so we have been
hearing from the friends and neighboring
countries of turkey that they're ready
to assist we heard a U.S national
security adviser Sullivan issuing a
statement saying that the United States
is also ready to help we heard Israel
and we heard there's a minister saying
that a swift aid program is being
prepared right now and as Azerbaijan two
kids one of the friendly and as Ankara
calls brother country is sending 370
Rescuers to help Turkish rescue workers
and in this big work that will be
ongoing intense different cities which
means many many people but this is a
very tragic situation in Turkey in Syria
and in surrounding areas that have been
affected by this great earthquake town
can you just tell us a little bit more
about the cities and the towns and and
the region uh for those of us that don't
know that area particularly well how
large are they how developed are they
uh well uh the earthquake mainly
affected the eastern and Southeastern
part of turkey and the epicenter Karma
Mirage is a Eastern Turkey the the the
earthquake was uh less than eight
kilometers deep so it was very close to
the surface according to the experts
this is why many cities 10 more cities
were directly affected for instance in
the morning when I first woke up with a
call from a friend by a friend in the
Arbuckle uh he he first thought that the
epicenter was the Abacus so the cities
that were also affected that were that
were not the epicenter also felt as if
they were the epicenter of this
earthquake and those Eastern cities some
of them are developed its densities some
of them are big some of them are small
but since turkey is prone to earthquakes
especially after 1999 earthquake and
Istanbul there was a new reg there have
been new regulations is on the building
structures so apparently what we'll look
when we look at to the news and when we
look at to the reports we see that the
new buildings that are in line with the
new uh earthquake regulation uh were
able to stay up but most of the
buildings that have a level so far are
the old buildings for instance in
Malaysia one of the most prominent
hotels in the city even though Malaysia
is one of the developed cities in East
Century one of the prominent hotels was
leveled we are hearing these kinds of
reports many apartment buildings haven't
leveled and people are trapped inside of
course
building quality is always a life
changer when it comes to earthquakes
even though it's a very very strong one
and do we know how some of the
infrastructure has held up under this
earthquake and and the aftershocks the
airports they're still open and what
about the health facilities as well
obviously the hospitals will be
inundated with the injured how are they
coping at this stage
uh well of course some of these Hospital
buildings are
damaged the airport s are open but the
weather condition is the challenging
Factor here Tom because to care has been
under heavy storms and snows for the
last couple of days even in Istanbul and
the Turkish capital Ankara it's been a
tough weekend for instance last night
even before the earthquake the flights
from Istanbul and Ankara to the Eastern
Turkey were canceled now we are we are
hearing that the the Turkish airline
company is going to launch more flights
to the region because also some medical
supplies and emergency aid supplies are
being transferred from big cities to the
area of uh via flights that's why more
flights are needed the main
infrastructures are are set to be safe
for now but for instance we we saw an
explosion a fire in some cities like
hatai after the earthquake but for
instance to the to some of the areas
natural gas has been cut in order to
avoid any kind of
explosions or fires they are taking the
officials are saying that they are
taking the necessary measures to avoid
any any kind of casualty or any extra
disaster that can be caused by this
earthquake but so far main
infrastructures are set to be safe
okay so you were speaking last hour
about the some of the bad weather that's
been affecting turkey what impact is
that having on the search and rescue
effort
foreign
are under heavy snow and the winter
conditions in that part of turkey
Eastern Turkey are always heavy and now
for instance in gaziantep we know that
people are outside trying to stay as
safe under snow in some cities there
there is heavy rain and these are of
course challenging the rescue workers
their work as they need to go inside the
leveled buildings they try and try to
rescue trapped people because of this
rain and snow it makes mud and it makes
the rescue work more difficult looking
from the civilian side it is more
challenging for the civilians as even
for a small earthquake you know people
get when it happens at night people are
scared they're frustrated they get
outside and until they feel safe they do
not return to their apartments or houses
and in this situation for the civilians
to stay stay outside under snow and rain
and when the weather is very cold it is
a difficult task and we don't know when
they will be able to return to their
homes even though their homes are not
damaged because so far since 8 is 6 30
a.m there has been at least 66
aftershocks and the strongest was 6.6
magnitude according to turkey's disaster
management agency which is a sign that
still there is a danger because even the
aftershocks are measured to be around
between five and six point six and the
reason of this is that a true case okay
so then we're going to have to interrupt
you there because the turkey as vice
president is speaking from anchor now
we're going to listen into him now
uh ready for operation regarding
hospitals I gave you the data some
hospitals
have been affected old buildings that
are hosting hospitals have been affected
and we are doing our best in order to
give assistance to the people we have
provided tents and some camps already in
the nearby areas
also
we have other creatures that have been
affected by the earthquake we have our
animals and in this we have cartels and
in this regard the mystery has formed a
committee
to provide the necessary support in
order to protect the animals from the
cold weather
and to protect the animals from the
consequences of this bad situation also
we have provided so many areas with the
necessary tent and equipment in order to
keep our wealth of animals turkey is
working hard doing its best to intervene
and to help
Within
the coordination of different govern
rates and coordination of different
Ministries risky operations have already
started and we are in contact
with every uh concerned party in this
regard and we have also received
information of so many countries that
are ready to help
we might request some medical supplies
medical equipment our citizens at the
same time are quite ready to help and
assist their brothers and sisters in
these disaster areas and we are
organizing this all together we will be
able to provide the needy people with
their needs of supplies and blanks and
Tents and in this connection action
there will be some bank accounts to
receive the donations and help
a fad will be doing this job
we urge our citizens to work hard to
help through effort once again my
condolences to our people and I wish
safety to everyone and they ask Allah
Almighty to keep us and to prevent us
from all disasters we know that turkey
is an Arab earthquakes so we have to
deal with this situation and we know
that the earthquake in itself is not the
main reason of deaths but the old
buildings are the main Regional cause of
the so many deaths and we need to get
our lesson and we will go
forward according to our preparations
and with the directions of the president
and the ministers we will be learning
our lesson and we will be estimating the
degrees and measures and volumes of how
to rescue our citizens this is our
priority this is our main
topic and Main matter to provide people
with food and water is also another
priority and the infrastructure has to
be taken off and insha Allah our areas
will be fine after the earthquake will
be able after the earthquake to operate
high on the uh the necessary speed it is
a big earthquake
uh but at the same time we appreciate
all the kinds of cooperation and
coordination between the members of our
people all safety for tokea all safety
for the Turkish people I'd like to thank
the speaker of the parliament and we are
here in Ankara doing our job
okay that was uh for what octo the vice
president of Turkey announcing that the
death toll has risen to 284 and some
flights have been suspended due to
damage at several airports uh in the
region we're going to go back to cinema
cosiolu who's monitoring developments
for us from Istanbul uh before we
um heard from the vice president there
you were speaking about some of the bad
weather that has been hampering the
search and rescue efforts can you just
tell us a little bit more about how they
are dealing with that and uh and and and
what effect that that is having
everything
welcome I have been speaking to people
living in gazi and the arbucker and
other places for instance in gaziantep
where also a huge number of Syrian
refugees are residing there is heavy
snow and people are outside people are
trying to stay in their cars that's why
some experts have been making calls at
the gas stations should provide free gas
to these people because they cannot go
inside and staying outside under snow is
impossible and we heard a Turkish vice
president saying that the gas line in
Mirage and gazian may take days to
repair so this is this is very important
that we are hearing from the vice
president and supplying gas to the area
hitting those warming up these people is
going to be very difficult and probably
they will need to take these places to
big buildings and even mosque so it is
very difficult for them to stay outside
because so far there are buildings that
have been damaged or that have been
leveled but the damage on the buildings
are not determined yet so is it safe to
go is is the main structure of those
buildings are safe to take back those
people it is still unknown and since
there are 10 cities that have been
affected by this big earthquake this
this seems to be uh there will be days
probably for them to go back inside
talking from the previous earthquake
experiences in Turkey even in eastern
anatologist two years ago so this is a
very tragic moment for especially the
civilians in Turkey right now it
certainly is thank you so much and we'll
no doubt be talking to you throughout
the day